hey y'all what up it's your girl live
sakoshi hi i'm sabrina carpenter what's
up i'm jordan fisher
yo i'm keenan lonsdale we're the cast of
worker and we're with buzzfeed
playing who's he
[Music]
why do you think so jordan remarkably
supportive of
of not just your best friend but of
everybody around you very hard-working
both great dancers
both very funny both very infectious and
just rays of sunshine to both of you i
was looking for compliments and i got
him thank you so much but i will say
that you are kind of like jake taylor
jordan fisher because
dick taylor sees you know potential and
all and unlocks it so that's what you do
you feel comfortable and confident
for the most part how people like i
think perceived juilliard is
is uh very different than than how
you're perceived you're the kindest
warmest like you're literally just a
you're a hug in a person
i'm real humble but myself eliza yeah
eliza
eliza no like you're everyone's favorite
child well you're all of our favorite
child we all love you
what and it's the impromptu pot too it's
like the first one out there
laying it there it is look at that
i would say sabrina but i feel that was
her tapping into quinacridone
i would say me also i will say that for
this movie specifically
i often did not fully learn the routines
but it was on purpose so i i didn't
always know exactly what i was doing
because that was a sure way to look like
terrible it was a beautiful enlightening
moment to get to watch sabrina
do that wonderful dancing uh audition
for the thunderbirds i think that was
the moment well that was one of the ones
i'm sure
the audition scene for the thunderbirds
i literally had no idea what i was doing
and i walked on the set and the two
girls that they placed in front of me
were literally what i was going off of
so i was always a count behind them
because
akuma and amy i never learned a single
step of that choreography
i think it's a real it's a real skill
jordan i think jordan has this natural
neck to pick up choreography
i think you just popped in and learned
it within a day yeah also like
both of our duets we like rehearse
together once
you would just hop in and i would have
been like rehearsing with some other
person for like
days and then you just hop in and be
like all right i got it and i'd be like
oh
that's very sweet i appreciate that
literally just because it was kind of
beaten into me
to be honest with you and training i
remember being 13 years old and walking
into my first like
drop-in dance class at millennium dance
complex in l.a and
marveling at how quickly all these
dancers around me some like even younger
than me to be honest with you
would just like watch a step and hit it
immediately and i'm like i have to
figure that out to learn how to do that
sabrina the tiniest thing in the room
the tiniest thing can eat the most
i eat honestly i didn't have a whole lot
of time to go to craft service i was i
was always on set
so i don't know i'd probably say keenan
i i've met you at crafty quite a few
times
yeah so you ran them parts
i know it very well i was going to say
me because i'm constantly grazing
all day but i think i don't know i think
that we all like make sure we take care
of ourselves
it's a safe place
there wasn't a lot of pranking that was
going on nate the guy that plays tapes
sleeps a lot the the most pranking that
was ever done on set was probably just
us
like doing photo shoots with him while
his mouth was open
and his chair sleeping that's probably
it
i think i'll be a dance mom for sure
like i want to gyrate
my thighs with my kid one day that'd be
fun well what liza said
but like for liza not for myself the
diary was my kid's leg
i'm i'm trying to like not be a dance
dad but i also know how competitive i
am and i know how much like i'm gonna
want my kid to do well
so i don't know i will i'll have to
we'll figure that out as we go
my kid's going to beat your kid though
for sure
we all know the answer to this it's it's
sabrina and liza it's
period yeah and it's only by force it's
because like
i mean she'd follow me like a puppy dog
like whatever room i went to like she'd
be there and i just felt rude if i
didn't talk to it so
uh yeah it'd be like
i'm kidding i love her with all my heart
i mean honestly like what's a shame is
like i didn't uh
i didn't have a lot of scenes with you
kiki all my scenes with jordan like
obviously we
we'd hang in between takes but then our
other scenes were with all the tv
so we'd all just be together there was a
lot of there was a qua a lot of quality
jazz quinn time though
uh sabrina and liza for sure i want i
want to manifest like a song with all
three of them on it i'm the only not
singer of the group
say i would love to have a project with
the three of us and like
liza like if you could throw in some
percussion with
rap honestly yeah give me some like
left eye you know what i'm saying give
me that
liza i was going to say me watching
liza do liza things
liza has this this just wonderful knack
of being able to
play whatever role she's playing but
also give a touch of liza in a way that
just
breaks everybody down it's a marvelous
showcase of
how genius her comedic timing and
choices are it's really great
turn this [ __ ] up
you